jassim is 22 years old and like many
young men his age
enjoys football he is autistic and his
mother says playing the sport in a safe
environment
has improved his life over the last two
years
after finishing school jason and those
like him had no chance to take part in
any activities
so he stayed at home and most of the
time doing nothing but now they come
here and free themselves of any negative
energy
anger or aggressiveness they wait
impatiently for this day every week
this program really grants them their
inherent right to life
and i hope it will run forever
jassim is benefiting from a sports
program here in doha
teaching those with special needs
several sports including football
the ability friendly football program is
a relatively new initiative but it's
already got the backing
of the qatar 2022 world cup organizers
and one of their most famous ambassadors
former australia captain tim cahill does
a lot of work with the world cup social
legacy division
generation amazing comes part and parcel
with who i am as a person
um i've had a great career but one of
the most magical things is
to be able to share my wealth of
knowledge to have fun with the kids
according to britain's national autistic
society physical activity can improve
social skills communication and anxiety
it creates a sense of belonging and it
creates an environment where anyone can
just quite simply be together and play
and it's through that process of having
fun and engaging
that like you see a genuine growth in
people's
ability to communicate and desire to
communicate as well
qatar's world cup organizers are aiming
to make next year's tournament the most
accessible ever
as well as providing dedicated areas for
those with physical disabilities
stadiums will host sensory rooms for
autistic people
to have a quiet space where they can
enjoy the matches
it's all about inclusiveness we talk
about inspiring the next generation and
this is the next generation and
as an ambassador and also as a father i
want to be a part of this
i hope more attention is paid to this
slice of our youth
simply because autistic people are very
intelligent and enjoy
many other talents their talents
wouldn't come to light
unless they're given the choice to
interact with their surroundings
with just over 20 months to go until the
tournament kicks off
the hard work continues to get qatar
ready to host the world cup
while also making it a welcoming
environment for all
joanna gazroska al jazeera dojo